the Joe Rogan experience what do you
think about this whole you're more
informed than me about international
issues I mean for Christ's sakes you
went to North Korea
you never been snails to the new at
Milan that's what I heard
what do you think about all this crazy
[ __ ] that's going on right now with Iran
I have a great book idea and it's such a
great book idea I'm gonna just drop it
here in the hopes that if I don't ever
do what someone does it give it away
yeah I'm gonna give it away I hope
somebody does this a lot of people do at
the same time to each other or no you
come on idea [ __ ] or some publisher
wants to contact my agent just give me a
deal on the spot I'll do it
okay blood you guys do it I'll do it so
what's not tell anybody well I don't
want to do the proposal so if they want
to just rob make me an offer
good blood lust the media's love affair
with war for a hundred years
spanish-american war Willie Randolph
Hearst right the sinking the Lusitania
we were taught about yellow journalism
when we're kids back you know the 1903
Oh bah bah bah bah blah but now it's not
they love war they can't get enough for
Trump is only presidential when he's
bombing Syria they just are desperate to
push the war drums and what I love about
again Tulsi is she's served and she's
like war we have to start seeing war as
a last resort instead of a first
priority in a first response and I don't
know what's going to happen as a
consequence of Iran this guy is most
people know sulemani was a huge deal
like he was really revered in Iran and
very hated by people elsewhere but Trump
also started killing other people and
like Yemen he took somebody out in some
other countries go they're going on a
killing spree so it's I don't think this
is going to be World War 3 at all
because Iran knows they can't win and
I'm sure right now but you know they're
doing exercise right now with Russia and
China sure let them do it sure we do
exercise with South Korea every year and
North Korea freaks out and it's like
okay we're just it's just flexing your
muscles right until I think very
strongly we're never gonna be privy to
this that there's a lot of stuff going
on behind the scenes that we don't know
that people are talking and like what's
going to happen I'm sure well there must
be but the idea that he was willing to
just do that and that he had
even has the call that he can make the
call like there's here's several options
sir right which one you want to do oh I
get that guy killed well I think it's
amazing that we've gotten to the point
where you're blowing up a wedding right
and you're killing a lot of people and
you're killing just him and one other
person
yeah they only killed two people that
like the precision of that is something
that's got to be scary to the Iranians
it should be scared to us yeah scary to
everybody because it's not like that
can't come over it here Oh what do you
mean that kind of technology can't be
used against Americans by another
country well I certainly could frankly
if they're gonna be terrorists I'd
rather they taking out one person than
3,000 no no for sure
I'm just saying the precision of it oh
yeah the fact that they have that kind
of ability just just the drone ability
in general there's the ability to wage
war in countries we don't even occupy
like the all the different drone attacks
in Yemen oh yeah really sketchy in terms
of like the legality of it like what
it's not really a military strike but
it's definitely a military strike I mean
I think we've been playing fast and
loose with the rules of war for a long
time and I think everyone knows this is
nothing particularly insightful that war
and the rules of war written by the
powerful people I remember when people
were talking about how much of a war
monger Obama was because drone strikes
went up considerably from Obama from
George Bush to Obama and I'm like you
know what else went up drone technology
yeah nothing to do with him they're just
getting better at bombing people they
you know how to do it better and this is
something I've argued people and wonder
about when you become prêt like Obama
was very anti-war through his campaign
he was a big lefty he went to all the
Ivy League schools but all right we know
his culture that he came from he gets in
the white house he's drone bombing
everybody what do you think that is the
question I have is do you think and I'll
get my Alex Jones hat on do you think
that they sit you down when you're
president and they're like all right
here's what you can be in charge of but
here's how it's going to be
internationally and I wouldn't be
surprised if that's the way it happens I
think there's no way until you get into
office you ever really understand what
information what you know what plans
that they can reveal that terrorists
have
what you know what kind of I mean
there's there's got to be some kind of
intelligence they receive that probably
scares the [ __ ] out of them oh yeah when
you stop and think about how many
nuclear bombs there are how many radical
terrorists there are how many different
sects how many people fight over each
other how here's here's some photographs
of a crime scene that we found that Isis
be had all these oh yeah it's like this
is all real stuff that you they could
show you and they go look we have done
our very best to keep everybody safe but
there's only one way to keep doing this
we got a drone bomb yeah I know I can't
drone away I know that many years ago
and I'm not supposed to know this but
I'll be all there was a nail bomb in
Grand Central that they caught in the no
one talked about no one talked about it
who found the nail bomb the the
authorities the right people and they
took care of it and nothing happened but
think how many soft targets there are at
overseas I mean that's what captain nail
bomb down must have been what at the
time while Qaeda I'm guessing I don't
know I don't have any further
information I'm gonna question you
further if you could question me all you
want
you gonna have microwatt aboard tell me
the story again so there's this place
Grand Central where the sky is been a
Grand Central of course I'm going into
the spot where the bomb was left
probably how do you know where the bones
live I don't know but ever since I've
been throughout Grand Central I follow
okay yeah okay tell me the story again
from the beginning this is how they do
it and they eventually get you oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah
[Applause]